Ever since he was first introduced in the
mid-credits scene at the end of the first
Avengers film, Thanos has loomed large in
the imaginations of Marvel fans.
Now that both Avengers: Infinity War and Avengers:
Endgame have come and gone, it's clear that
the masterminds behind the Marvel Cinematic
Universe had big plans for Thanos going back
years.
But just what those plans were definitely
changed from that first appearance and in
the case of Guardians of the Galaxy, they
apparently changed quite a bit.
According to Charlie Wen, former head of visual
development for Marvel Studios, there were
plans to make Thanos a much bigger part of
the first cosmic movie in the MCU.
He explained to us via email:
"Thanos' role would have been significantly
larger.
We would have seen some of the relationship
[and] tensions play out between him and his
kids [...] Ronan's role would have decreased,
with Thanos taking on more."
Wen was responsible for bringing the earliest
versions of Thanos from the comic book page
to the big screen.
And since the Mad Titan was going to be a
major player for the growing MCU early on,
Wen knew he had to get the details right to
communicate that threat at a glance.
"Early on, Thanos was setting up to be a major
climax for the MCU, but the first time I designed
Thanos was for his first appearance in Avengers.
His armor had to reflect the look of his iconic
comic book origins (while being more practical)
as well as a nod to his Chitauri soldiers
in the film.
"Because he was going to play such a defining
role in the MCU later, it was important to
capture the look that fans know of him: an
enormous bulky purple frame, bluish fabric,
complemented by a golden armor in the shape
of a slight crescent moon accentuating his
shoulders, leading up to large slits along
his chin, and finally capped by a helmet that
reflects the shape language of his body armor."
But as time went on, Avengers writer-director
Joss Whedon reportedly made the call to diminish
Thanos's role in the early stages of the MCU
to make for a more satisfying build-up over
time.
That meant changes to work being done on Guardians
of the Galaxy during pre-production.
And then, after making those changes, making
even more changes.
Wen explained:
"It was decided to cut Thanos out of Guardians
completely in order to have a slower reveal
of him.
It wasn't until right before the shoot that
I was told that Thanos would have a role in
the film, so designing him and his throne
was pretty rushed.
[...] I only had a couple days left to design
him on his throne.
I made some improvements from the first design,
in which we saw the side of his face."
As for the throne itself, it's fascinating
to look at some of Wen's concept art from
throughout his tenure at Marvel Studios to
see how the MCU's plans for Thanos and his
throne evolved.
For instance, in two concept images that Wen
labeled "Ronan Ceremony," we see the Mad Titan
holding court on a rocky throne, with Ronan
and Nebula standing before him as an audience
of aliens watch.
But that's not quite the scene we get in the
film.
When Nebula and Ronan appear before Thanos,
there's no audience, and Thanos's throne is
markedly different.
As to where Wen got the idea to create the
floating platforms that made up Thanos's throne,
the answer lies in concept art he did for
a different Marvel Studios film just a few
years earlier: the very first Thor feature.
Since that movie was so early in the MCU's
evolution, Wen worked hard to find as many
different takes on the movie's important characters
as he could and that included this very sci-fi
influenced version of Thor's dad, Odin.
That throne design didn't make it into Thor,
but it seems to have found a second life under
Thanos for Guardians of the Galaxy.
But enough about Thanos's butt what about
his face?
Even though Josh Brolin played the character
in the first Guardians of the Galaxy film,
it's easy to see that the character didn't
really resemble the actor very much at least,
not to the extent that the Thanos of Infinity
War did.
There's a reason for that, explained Wen:
during the pre-production phase on Guardians
of the Galaxy, Brolin hadn't yet been cast
in the part.
"It was on Infinity War that Josh Brolin's
face needed to be incorporated.
By then, I'd left Marvel, and my partner in
crime, and co-head of Marvel's Visual Development
Ryan Meinerding, did the honors and designed
the version in that film."
With Avengers: Endgame setting records and
revealing Thanos's fate to fans all over the
world, it's exciting to wonder how different
things could've been if Marvel Studios had
stuck with their initial plans to give Thanos
a bigger presence in the original Guardians
of the Galaxy.
Would he have ended up making as big of an
impact?
To that, Marvel fans can only say "What if…"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
supervillains are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.